bonsoir je m'appelle viennent j'ai 15
ans et je suis sain pour commencer je
dois dire que je dessine depuis que j'ai
deux ans ce qui n'a rien d'exceptionnel
parce que tous les enfants de cet âge là
des signes et je suis sûr que dans cette
salle vous avez tous pris un crayon un
feutre et recouvert les feuilles à vos
créations avec 5 des applications ce qui
s'est passé pour moi c'est tout
simplement que je n'ai pas arrêté
on a plupart de mes camarades de
renoncer aux joies du gribouillage
cependant le dessin n'était pas une
passion en soit c'était un moyen
d'expression alors d'expression
merveilleux que je vais approprié qui
permettait donner forme à des idées
palpation je me suis intéressé à 10 ans
domaine mais à chaque poste a traduit
ses souhaits forme de trait sur du
papier j'ai fait du dessin d'observation
quand je suis intéressé la biologie et
des cartes quand je me pencher sur la
géographie la géopolitique et puis un
jour j'ai pris conscience que le dessin
était le fil conducteur entre tous et
sans intérêt et qu'il avait toujours été
là quoi que je fasse ce qu'il semble
aussi intéressant c'est que j'ai
toujours monter des projets avant même
de les montrer un véritable public
je faisais des séries b st sur un thème
dans un style que je m'entraîne la
famille je suis sûr que beaucoup d'entre
vous font ça aussi comme vous il me
manquait une chose
la simple idée qui m'était possible d'en
faire quelque chose que d'autres
personnes pouvaient être intéressés par
ce que je faisais et puis un jour ma
mère va parler d'un appel à projets que
l'ancien centre d'art une institution
artistique de la ville de mener 1 à ce
moment là je m'intéressais à la première
guerre mondiale
et comme j'avais vu un roulement sur ce
sujet qui m'avait
titulaire en touche et a lancé un
nouveau d'erich maria remarque que je
vous recommande fortement
j'en avais illustrer certains passages
aujourd'hui l'on dit pourquoi cette fois
ne pas essayer de montrer ce que je fais
ça ne changerait pas de ce que je
faisais de d'habitude mais simplement
cette fois j'essaierai de le montrer un
autre public dans une exposition
et si ça ne fonctionnait pas je le ferai
quand même comme d'habitude c'est comme
ça que j'ai lu règlement g par super
bien compris mais j'ai quand même
procéda telle exposition
j'ai été reçu et j'ai pu participer à
cette exposition et s'est affiché
découvert un monde complètement sous ce
mot il y avait des artistes dans ma vie
juste à côté de chez moi qui créent tous
les jours il me suffisait d'aller les
voir de leur montrer ce que je faisais
pour échanger et partager avec eux j'ai
pris conscience de tout ce que je
voulais dire de tout ce que je voulais
montrer et vous mettez possible de faire
en essayant faisant des erreurs et après
dans ces dernières et ça à peu près au
moment de cette prise de conscience que
en baladant dans les rues nommer un
comme ça m'arrive souvent j'ai découvert
une maison coloniale que je ne
connaissais pas les maisons coloniales
sont magnifiques
ce sont souvent elles qui retiennent mon
attention quand je me balade dans les
rues et je m'était déjà arrivé d'en
dessiner quelques unes mais dans ce jour
là devant cette maison je n'avais pas
mon matériel de dessin sûrement
j'ai donc décidé de revenir un autre
jour et effectivement une auto semaine
après cela je suis revenu et il restait
des ruines
la première réaction fut la dessiner
quand même dessiné des rues donc je me
suis dit c'est le meilleur moyen de
rendre hommage et ça donne du sens à
bord dessins dessiner cette destruction
témoigner en quelques sortes
j'ai donc dans les mois qui suivirent
réalise
trois planches de bandes dessinées sur
cette destruction je travaille assez
lentement mais là encore je n'étais pas
satisfait car ces dessins était resté
dans mon coeur pour un dessin et je
voulais partager ce message et pourquoi
pas ici n'est pas un art narratif comme
la bande dessinée mais encore plus
accessible le moyen idéal de raconter
sous une autre forme
l'histoire de saison c'est alors que
j'ai imaginé l'histoire d'un homme d'une
cinquantaine d'années qui passeraient
tous les jours devant une maison que le
diable pour aller au travail ils tirent
jour dès ce prêt de s'arrêter pour
rencontrer la propriétaire de la maison
essayez de l'acheter je ne savais pas
comment écrire un scénario
mais j'avais chaque cadrage et mais
chaque montage en tête
je me suis donc dit essayons de
retranscrire le plus fidèlement possible
ce que j'ai en tête sur une feuille de
papier
j'avais entendu parler du bureau
d'accueil des tournages je les ai
contactés je leur envoyais mon scénario
qui n'en avait pas grand chose d'un et
je répondais comme je connaissais rien
du cinéma qu'elle ait des liens comment
puis-je faire ce film
ici en nouvelle calédonie ils m'ont
orienté vers des bourrades à la
réalisation
ils m'ont fait envie de rencontrer les
techniciens des réalisateurs pour monter
une équipe
un budget et réaliser le chine
qu'aujourd'hui une maison mais cela
reste une fiction pour changer le
quotidien des nommés inchangé les
esprits j'avais besoin d'un projet qui
puisse être vu de la rue qui puisse
attirer l'attention un simple passant et
c'est là que je suis retombé sur le
travail du tri d'artistes jr pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas ils réalisent
depuis une dizaine d'années des immenses
portraits en noir et blanc qui collent
sur les murs du ville des villes du
monde entier comme ici au brésil aux
états unis ou en chine
je me suis mis à me documenter sur son
travail et c'est là que j'ai découvert
son projet insiders
le principe est simple permettre à
quiconque de partager un message ou un
engagement à travers la réalisation de
portraits xxl en noir et blanc est donc
à ce moment-là tout à fait sens pour moi
ce projet d'arrêté de partager un
message
travers le collage de portraits sur les
murs or justement ce que je voulais
dénoncer
c'était la destruction durant siens
alors pourquoi ne pas dénoncer cette
destruction entre en collant des
portraits sur des murs ça vous paraît
peut-être à l'impliquer comme ça mais
pour moi à ce moment-là dans l'agencé
vous plutôt de lave et roncq j'ai
contacté la ville réalisatrice laly
connaît tous hilali photographie
download et leur ai présenté deux
projets qu'elles ont compris et accepté
bd réalisée d'un commun accord nous
avons décidé de ne photographier que des
jeunes car ce sont les héritiers de ce
patrimoine en danger
nous nous sommes rendus sur la place
principale de nommer à la place des
cocotiers à vous arrêter des gens dans
la rue expliqué projet demandé s'il
voulait bien cesser prendre en photo est
presque toujours il a accepté et c'est
comme ça que un mois et demi après le
début du projet nous avons reçu les
affiches et deux jours plus tard un
dimanche les colons sur les restes d'une
maison coloniale détruite en début
d'année roue de lozada un des axes
majeurs de la route de nos mères et le
lendemain matin nous avons pu voir les
automobilistes à ralentir en allant au
travail devant nos visages intrigué il
passe tous les jours devant cette maison
sans l'avoir mais nous porterons donner
un visage à ce mur permettant lui rendre
un dernier hommage avant qu'il ne
disparaisse pour toujours une même envie
un même thème un même désir mais des
moyens d'expression différents débits
lieu différent des optiques différentes
pourquoi limiter la rallye technique
l'art est un moyen c'est stream et de
véhiculer les messages émotions
latéritique le support de juste 4 le
plus adapté à ce que l'on veut partager
de même je pense qu'il faut tout essayer
et non pas pour se spécialiser
non pas pour choisir les voies mais
justement pour s'enrichir être à même de
pouvoir dire le pouvoir hurler si
nécessaire avec le plus de pertinence et
de force nous histoire nos visions et
nos idées et si je n'étais pas à même de
réaliser moi-même c'est ce projet les de
ses désirs j'ai pas hésiter à contacter
d'autres artistes peut-être plus
compétents fois pour les premiers
en oeuvre concrètement pour cela il m'a
fallu apprendre à communiquer ce désir
mais travailler en collaboration avec
d'autres artistes a été une des
expériences les plus enrichissantes qui
avait été donné de vivre qu'un projet
est par essence collectif aujourd'hui ce
ne sont plus les maisons coloniales qui
m'intéresse mais la ville elle même
qu'est-ce que nous bien qu'ils sont ceux
qui vivent y travaillent et la traverse
tous les jours et à travers cette
question qui sont les calédoniens qui
seront ils demain une seule oeuvre un
seul projet et même un seul artiste ne
peuvent répondre à telle question mais à
travers du street art de la photographie
du dessin animé de la fiction du
documentaire il me semble possible de
dresser face et après facettes un
portrait une esquisse maladroite
peut-être parce qu'aujourd'hui notre
quotidien dans cette ville bien sûr ils
mettent plus en plus difficile de
conserver ces conditions je suis
aujourd'hui en première et bientôt il me
faudra choisir rester en nouvelle
calédonie pour apprendre en autodidacte
au fil de mes projets ou partir à
l'étranger faire des études pour
m'améliorer dans ce cas aussi il
faudrait choisir des saintes cinéma quel
que soit mon choix eh bien tu ne sois
très difficile de me projeter mettre
dans un futur proche je suis à présent
sûr d'une chose simple et essentielle
ce n'est ni votre âge et votre
expérience et vos origines qui doivent
nous empêcher de monter un projet car
c'est notre désir qui est essentiel il
existe on
il lui est impossible de mourir il peut
évoluer prendre diverses formes et s'il
nous en prenons conscience et si nous
nous ont confiance naître sous l'avant
d'un projet qui n'est que l'expression
et le partage de notre vision de notre
désir
merci
et